hello and welcome to this video I'm
going to play something I have not
played yet and only super blitz arena I
have no idea how strong this thing is
actually it takes 50 minutes so let's
see I wonder if I maybe can this is
buzzer King right the berserk every game
said an option Lionel could be
interesting maybe I'm just making a
total fool of myself but I can try okay
you know this is a bit hectic out if you
do do the semi game I guess we'll see
what happens is interesting looks like
the e5 pawn is a bit weak
but at least I'm well develop them it
must not not necessarily the end of the
world that I lost the spawn
I'm so very active see ok you can jump
into d6 but like you might even take B 3
and B 2 yeah I think taking there was an
option I really don't have much down I'm
not threatening you
almost easier to take and play out the
air that's almost the threat still not
so easy for him maybe before b5 you
cannot take because of Bishop d6 stick I
think II five is a move
trying to activate a group we should be
three areas for Bishop c5 I'm a little
bit late joining this for just a couple
of minutes acting trying to get this
pawn back which worked but now I'm a
little bit better because of the
activity intending real book a form this
isn't a problem
cannot color a seven I think cheek first
think later okay him the king will help
to promote the b-pawn this is quite
hectic am with the deserting okay so on
minutes to win the first one getting
three points and yeah I should get more
games and with the deserting but I will
definitely do something on time it's
it's absolutely given I'm not that quick
maybe you have dessert actually I
actually have M playing quickly because
I'm going over this thing that I have to
speed up the enolate counter gambit and
now white will ask himself what is going
on with this you know that doesn't work
okay while it's just a piece down
and my development is much better so
maybe the check even put them out in the
open even more
let's just play them in Pisa easy win
even with one minute just let trade down
near the thing is trapped
oh and he resigns so free berserk wins
in
Oh to berserks
two faces oak wincing it was not well
charged let's see five probably was
quite good yeah okay not a big deal okay
let's see I would like to have more
tinier to be honest because this is
actually rather fragile position you
want to check details
yeah like this usually taking with the
Knights it's not a good idea in such a
situation but here it doesn't work of
course and like it's very very ok
try to win b6 Godric a6 which is very
fine okay
maybe I can to son reform yeah not not
nice really like it's fine in this is
this is a good ending though b6 I think
I can take take take take
kingi to back d7 and 97 I mean might be
a good ending might be a good ending
I've no time are the bouzouki the buzzer
King it should
this position is actually really good
now I think with Jim the times obviously
a problem ever managed seconds almost
seem 8 if not King at six
okay tough
okay super placed Oh even though I'm
constantly preserving it who took me a
bit long to realize that I would like 30
seconds left
[Music]
luscious Philomath let's add it the
leader of this event actually please not
set on terrible of course yeah here this
looks like you quite reasonable telecoms
in f5 is a good move him but then I came
the time is the issue
I have firm I'm committed to berserk
King so h5 maybe it's not clear that
this doesn't work I have night each and
I've recognized f5 stuff and c4 is
hanging and this is trying trying to be
practical here hmm
that doesn't work really and 5 doesn't
work maybe I mean with the time I should
just go with its meaning
90 a droopy eight maybe just canceled
short then still not totally easy I
guess no actually the same okay I was
made okay tough and tough if you're busy
in the game especially if the opponent
is good so just took the center it could
have taken me five that it was
reasonable actually well that looks good
I'm preventing c6 and d6 it's normally a
good thing to do f1 it has no square
now after a three g4 is not available it
didn't react to that there's some
trickier c5 no you can just take that
I'm all that quite a bit here
so just a piece 97 winning the queen is
the idea I can check actually oops yeah
I'm such an idiot game why not play a
Nolan Bob and win automatically stupid
stuff that was really stupid
I could have just won automatically with
technical plane being the peas up now I
have to win this with the with the bunch
of pawns but it was a lot easier it
could have been a lot easier
push the Queen back doesn't really have
good squares available and when tonight
only five are to blame this is also
would also be nice if trade the Queen's
yeah
no the a pawn is strong enough to win on
its own
rook the eight
pshh I have six we can just take p5 go
to the eight new so it was not very
intelligent to give in the piece back
and with Quincy firechek got enough time
leading this event who is successful
even if you win every game with buzzer
King and still you don't lead
maybe I'm just playing too slowly
oh okay okay now I go to five points and
so I'm leaving again let's go many
people flip provoked with the berserk
and then they play the King again bird
and you get those kind of games is it
funny we should see fire this even
better him winning the Queen okay give
me more of those they at least once in a
while just give me five points and
that's good you don't gain more rating
points though it just helps him with
them very quickly
I don't have much in probably nothing
actually but okay what can you do
probably this for 496 this is Sir it
tastes a little idea that I have in this
position it's not not that comfortable
here fun if I can double on the making
it give him a double pawn damn it is
going to be a little bit awkward okay
but that gives me these five right okay
so that looks good all of the Sun I'm 15
points ahead a couple of quick the Zerg
wins really do a good job down oh I'm
Talia our plans for wrongly pronounced
another Kings gambit may be another
quick win it would have been funny Oh me
I can get an age 6 FG 5 I will
definitely play that I can certainly and
I think quick play yonder hi humans
still play d4 but currently currently I
will be able to take it because of the
pin so d4 this bug immediately came to
take and now this one for the G foul
yeah I think he played this really okay
I'm that looked like a good play for
white from white don't ever and you know
we cannot do that I is playing well look
at cleanup one now and I'm basically and
basically busted yeah shoot I shouldn't
have played this this unsound stuff
this particular case I think age 65
wasn't good okay but maybe I'm not
totally lost position is not good might
not be lost entirely right c5 Knight f6
soups all kinds of things I 5 no eggs ok
may we'll take it he will take it no he
won't
then it continues you know the time is
not on my side quickly bring the knight
on to d3
question f3 I need to try to play for me
it with 20 seconds it's going to be
difficult to win normally how can i play
for made double on the G file I guess
oops and see that one coming 90 forum
threatens o6 unfortunately alright it's
doing a really good job here irritating
me
it takes a rupee one might be good king
of three I don't have rook F 1
unfortunately he's escaping all the way
don't leave this nonsense scaping all
the way
nope yeah it was close man oh crap
ah I was really risky even giving you
the look for nothing at the end
okay anyway okay please please play
meeting yes I shouldn't have done that
it was a little bit no this should be
seven of course I wanted to play and now
white is winning and you Canada should
be send was still interesting this you
cannot stand them unfortunately ah yeah
of course that's easy and winning
ninety-six check is the problem
ninety-six after sacrifice the Queen it
doesn't even do it
yeah 96 is still good
anyway if I miss any opportunity chance
would be connected with somehow
counselling long maybe six cows alone
maybe and then try to do stuff on the
edge wow it's actually still somewhat
somewhat interesting hmm
care to what was made it possible
[Music]
yep she sucks coming good really doesn't
really work of course it's still got
some ideas
Knight h3 somewhat of a problem it's not
really threatening much between a 3 2 c1
or something cannot take his threatening
itself
yeah they can prove f72 swin also and he
can take them out okay now that was that
opening was too bad absolutely too bad
all those two games cost like 80 raging
points or something
I think the deserting is not good for
for the rating and then add an opening
apply to number two and the mouse Libya
you cannot stand the mouse level in such
an extreme position the mouse cage was
basically losing lots of pressure here
I'm like Bishop f4 maybe Black has a
hard time to develop here the capsule on
Bishop is exerting lots of pressure
aside I think 95 will probably be good
now wins this pawn no I have touched
like this first there should be 6 m2 bit
of an a bit of an issue
yeah because all screaming please God
picks going on Bishop d7 I also cannot
so easily play here I play against and
okay
did I screw this up yeah a little bit
no I was exciting 'king Bishop d7 and
now we play in it this is this is I
think okay for me it's very tough for
him to defend the Queen side how would
you see cover b7 in the first place okay
this one interesting I have two pounds
already so I need to be hectic
I mean position wise time wise I
probably need to be hectic
the surprising that boom twenty seconds
this ending is a lot better for white
with 20 seconds and a bit of a problem
you cannot pre move or anything it's
just the too many things going
you manage this em to sell okay no a
minute
no a c'mon
Harlequin g3 some free mouthing tough
yeah yeah yeah the berserk anus makes it
much more difficult I think if I just
play with a normal time see I committed
to do it like that
take the six if you try it looks like a
pretty nice fringe defense maybe I
should have played before you know just
a form preventing c5
maybe I can close this down I don't know
if he really dance to bread one before
no it's a bit of a gamble I think you
could have taken so let's see we'll
trade this Bishop age form no no we're
not trade I could have taken this but
okay this is not bad quite Kelly
96 is the only thing the night is pretty
annoying but I think I can just run up
with the king now I don't need to do
that
okay I need to just needed some point
yeah okay Scott for quite a while I
think I'm still hot and we favorite how
problem could be like playing against
like challenges why I have to be Zerg
this guy is actually highly rated down
how weird how weird the thing is this is
not all the great white but it has taken
me ages to make sure you point it and
got the easy to do much here out of this
completely barren position it was
completely equal
still I mean I get boobs
I get two we can spawn structure
slightly that doesn't really mean all
that much okay still not much going on
he has route d6 all the time but didn't
play it okay
slides able to win the b-pawn and we win
the beef on 30 seconds is the thing it
was surprising
I can do that at 20 cents something
seconds now you're not playing come on
it doesn't make any sense just resign if
you don't intend to move okay
what does it mean actually the red bomb
I don't know I hope I'm not the one
being disconnected or something but I
don't think I am always fire I can know
II resigned and I got a couple of points
so six points ahead there is there is I
think one more game to be played if I
get the challenges fine and I have to
desert will be tricky but I don't think
he can win six points like it's not very
exciting
maybe I shouldn't have canceled I don't
know we should be six and as it should
be okay
cannot be bad for LA for Blackie
I'm not saying it's great but it
shouldn't be terrible going after this
kind of this kind of position is
probably just slightly better for white
and it's really not easy for me to
generate some ideas maybe this sim if he
goes a five I might be able to
play against the porn somehow
for example bish attending I can maybe
winter but with Nepal altogether
non-threatening look at four which is
kind of noise prevented that catching up
a bit on the clock cannot take it with
his king is weakened now the sole
accomplishment Atlas don't really see
anything grade activate Duke maybe can
no tech d3 so he wants to check me Queen
detours is a threat though I don't know
how dangerous is it might be dangerous
hood I think he gambled that didn't
Drake calculated all that thoroughly
yeah this is text exhibition takes
cheeks came
I can go to a seven that's what I
thought I calculated and I don't think
it can cover g3 now don't sell [ __ ]
alcohol mate whoo that that was lucky
with 12 seconds on the clock to get the
maiden oh okay
so two minutes left I don't know if new
game will be started in the first place
I think this guy is one all games right
without any berserks doing the solid
route just be a pastor half in 94 anyway
it doesn't really met all that much I
get to take on every and damage his bone
structure there okay
might might be able to win this even in
this short time that's funny that's
funny yeah and he resides so I got a
surprisingly quick winning so one minute
something left and the tournament
pairings are closed so I'm going to to
win this but I lost 40 great in points
with those losses in the middle of the
tournament I don't think I can actually
click there yeah I noticed this these
two games here that was this black
Blackie game in the Italian which was
really crazy and this year I also that
that was a really clean loss here
against batsman so I got 14 games in
berserk right 100%
yeah well okay and I can click here and
he won all games no deserves just win
all the games looks very very reasonable
okay I hope you enjoyed this video it
was something else that I think was
entertaining the rapid chess and sled
that I can and it doesn't make sense but
I don't think it every day during the
tournament yeah I hope you enjoyed it
how long if I get some positive feedback
I will do this again even though the
constant buzzer King is quite a hectic
yeah I really have to admit oh my
goodness I was loud that was really loud
and something that I don't need to
really do in every single time kind of
stressful
yeah thanks for watching bye bye